[Music]
in Mill escorts love news take care of
me okay male escort yeah there's a meal
escort and I said it and I said it
sounds fun you get to go and eat and
talk with someone but you're assuming
that the person you have to talk to you
actually vibe with them or they even
brush their teeth right I talked to a
lot of people that I don't even like and
care about I think every dude would be
like would be a what is it a lap boy
like a well-kept boy I kept boy you just
liked it you wanted as an escort I don't
want to be an escort but I would like
somebody look at me if you like you
could be an estimation wanted you know
pretend that I'm a dog and then bring
them slippers in a newspaper and issues
brawls lower those guys that higher
women so you could make it pay use your
money no I don't want to take my money
my money's precious I want to get paid
to do that my self-respect is it but my
money is I want to get paid to that's
where the desire is awesome dude that
wanted to pay this girl [ __ ] ton of
money to be a pet but not like a sex pet
you wanted her to walk her in cat ears a
collar and just [ __ ] walk around the
house and that's kind of sex walk around
her crawl around might be the animal no
need for that walking around to the
other leash I won't be a good cat I want
to provide the best service that I can
and a cat is not my thing
no cats the easiest though you just say
hi once and you disappear until a hard
worker because can you disappear go to
us a neighbor's yard get their food
whack your [ __ ] tail with attitude oh
yeah I like that they call you you flick
it up anything [ __ ] floats back down
yeah when they're licking themselves on
one leg straight up in the air that's
just weird as [ __ ] like me I do
something like this
Oh would they make biscuits oh it's just
so cute dude me like even close good
annoying when a cat is hungry though I
shut the [ __ ] up dogs don't do that
they just [ __ ] starving till they die
tonight but still playing with me even
though I'm hungry submitted by George
from Down Under
damn Yong Seon under the Allender a
high-end ladies club in China will shut
down after a police raid why what's up
now mate they have so many of those in
Japan and all the guys look like like
pretty pretty pretty pretty pretty ass
[ __ ] yeah no but you see the posters
outside I might change it good so
they're all hot I don't think she was
there walking back there Jess was like
those fools man we were all together no
I feel like you were the one that was
not with us yeah you like jakku I was
there too but I remembered that hosting
boy at the billboards oh you weren't
walking with us because it was that and
you had Isaac so you're like god I'm
gonna go different way I ain't babe your
mama that I think hosts boys you
remember Gina got his last and we're
walking around all over that [ __ ] oh
maybe you were with us it doesn't matter
why do we do this all the time
it does matter I want to see a host boy
okay I'm sorry
look I'm Japanese host boy this takes
place in Shanghai this very expensive
private club and Shanghai don't know
what the Ching hai host boy looks like
she's about to show you probably pretty
too
maybe not let's see this [ __ ] so this
private club for women it's called
perfect space uh-uh so here's some fun I
bet you they wear shiny shoes mm there
are shoes are different right shiny
shoes very different from what I
pictured yeah very different yeah
shirtless guy they call it or what oh I
got cold looking at that it looks
calling them yeah it looks like they
don't want a pantsless guy huh just the
dog I don't want the hole cut out where
the dong is I want them to be too cold
like this shirt was ripped off but for
some reason the state honor magic trick
where they take the thing off that where
they take the [ __ ] function right now
she got so upset with herself they're
like I pulled a tiger you're learning
friend now I just get frustrated I cry
it went viral this post went viral on
WeChat because one of the escorts the
male escort celebrated his 28th birthday
and this one woman gave him 28 gifts and
one of them included 28 dicks or one of
them was an Audi the son was a Gold Cup
and then another one was 280 thousand
won which is about $41,000 it's a boss
ass lady what'd she do sell socks Wow
everyone needs socks that's a great
thing again inside I feel like there's a
Chinese factory making all the song oh
yeah and then so we have 19 VIP boxes in
this club I don't even got [ __ ] these
ladies it's crazy they just want like
yeah they said that there's AG no legal
activity years enough but because of
that going viral yeah we could talk
about a lot of [ __ ] right that's crazy
you have you ever seen like an
attractive man just getting [ __ ] thrown
at them it's so [ __ ] odd because I
usually see it happen to women but
seeing that happened to a dude is so far
I've seen girls throw their [ __ ] at a
guy through the
eyes before wow I've never seen that
happen in real life
and until Bradley Martin were nice to go
to like the expose and I see him all the
time I see all the Instagram girl
athletes they see him and they're
literally like [ __ ] throwing their
clitoris through their eyes at him and
they're just [ __ ] white tripping down
there just but I was like that's what
girls do the guys I have never seen a
guy do that to girl and I saw Bradley
Martin it's weird not even like he's
just walking around and you see girls
like oh but you seem like a version of
that like when you go to bars and [ __ ]
like you'll see like an attractive
[ __ ] dude right like even me like I
walk into the bar look at the guy I'm
like that guy needs to be [ __ ] yes you
by anybody dude they're just like super
clean-cut very handsome they're not even
like flaunting it but these [ __ ]
they're just laughing like he said the
funniest [ __ ] thing on earth dude yep
hey what's your name mom's gonna get
this drink you didn't answer the right
question you [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm like
witnessing this [ __ ] and it's so wild
cuz I only see that happen to girls but
they a few occasion that happens to a
guy I wonder what it's like to be like
and they're not starts making oohs like
hi getting ready for physical touch
you'll see the girl laughs a little more
they're like grab oh you're so funny
it's a virgin
buddy yeah that's crazy yeah dude I'm
like what's it like to be you're so
funny
like leaving a trail of [ __ ] juice on I
think there's a wipe see the [ __ ] what
like what's name who's married to
Victoria Beckham David Beckham can you
imagine what he goes through
oh [ __ ] Christ dude dick and [ __ ]
flying in don't wonder a lot of
good-looking guys become day oh god
David Beckham style holy [ __ ] man that's
like every everyone even do it's
probably hit on him dude guy homie one
of the most best things about [ __ ] is
the challenge of trying to get one the
greatest joys of [ __ ] is that is the
challenge the challenge yeah they just
came I mean like it's like this like you
know we go to the strip club what the
net is saying that it's like what these
guys go to a bar right it's literally
fishing they go to a lake they
accomplished nothing today okay they go
away you know oh Jesus man guys are
gross no it's not you know pretty gross
I'm like being John Malkovich you could
be like in like another person or
whatever what if you could do that for a
really hot guy like what would you do
would you just [ __ ] every woman that
throw themselves at you
no I still have my morals I just want to
know what it feels like to be wanted
without having to work for it you know
I'm saying there's a lot of fangirls
that way but I got the I guess I have to
give all my way to the [ __ ] I can't
like these guys used to walk in and it's
just just [ __ ] everywhere it's the
level of girls
yeah and girls yeah sometimes they're
like a three you know yeah a 2-1 you
know but then like dude that we're
talking about
it's like consistently hands
yeah [ __ ] they got a [ __ ] bat labia
eyes that are just looking at them it's
way different yeah it's like those women
that you look at that you know guys will
type like I can't wait to [ __ ] you
don't know what I would do with that
asked I really wouldn't know what to do
with that ass like if it came up to me I
just blink I don't know I don't know
what to do with this because but I bet
you'd go down yeah they're standard just
like it keeps going up so it's like it's
like that's right we had a dream car but
once you make that much it's not really
that dream car anymore yeah so then now
it's like what do you do you [ __ ] Donuts
got a t-shirt what do you do but no nuts
you [ __ ] the whole out of that donut no
it's like imagine if you don't even have
to work for it and then now all these
girls just always on you and you're just
like man what am I gonna find somebody
that loves me for me those guys always
settle for like the average girls I mean
I'd be almost you know like this is a
nice girl next door dad does any get
marry I want to see what Dan Bilzerian
looks like without that beard I call
that shovel face disabled treatment it
looks like he'll see he looks like him
the beard really makes hair there are
certain people who just cannot live
without a beard yeah it also makes the
mystery of a chiseled face dan Bilzerian
definitely take steroids oh yeah for
sure that's a good pictures and there's
another picture I saw a young man look
is cool there's another picture I saw
which one that's why the one that I use
ball no oh yeah that's what I saw it's
not him okay
yeah maybe that's why I was like shovel
face I think yeah hey it doesn't look
that bad without it he doesn't like
history doesn't like the object of all
women though he's kind of just like he's
more like the object of guys yeah guys
want to be yeah yeah lower Jack yeah
Daniel Henney is a very old
beautiful zero in x-men and he's Daniel
Henney is dude that falls like The
Bachelor Korean and Hawaii missile even
still he's a bachelor
hi please name all I mean thank you
still attractive yeah how that old
Chinese guy that's that still looks like
he's in his 20s Jackie Chan 666 teas
fine or 50 you know you mean that
Chinese bodybuilder that grandpa is fair
can't have it all bit he wasn't big hero
6 yeah he was one of the voices yeah
with all the brother of the fanatic
yeah well you guys can call them
yourself because the Internet is really
[Music]